hey everybody I'm Pete Holmes please
watch crashing on HBO this Sunday at
10:00 p.m. and Sundays in general at
10:00 p.m. and on HBO go whenever you
want I'm here to answer the Internet
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna get gonna get skeeted on
tonight you think there are more porn
stars or murderers in the world porn
stars
I've never been to X murderers calm
there's so many disagree Playboy Mansion
that's I'm counting it
those are porn stars you don't think so
you're talking about we have penetration
penetration are better than I'm gonna
say exactly the same number how long
would it take you to drink all of the
water in an above-ground pool fresh
water no chemicals I'm gonna that's
gotta be at least three months ready
you can't drink that and you kind of
taste yourself in there like I should
have showered before this the one
celebrity birthday party you would want
to attend just because it's fun to say
Skeet Ulrich I just wanted I didn't want
to say this is now yeah tonight I can't
I'm going to Skeets yeah I'm gonna get
gonna get skeeted on tonight if you were
in a real-life Hunger Games yeah and had
to choose one fictional character to be
your partner who would you pick Dwayne
the rock Johnson I mean who sent this in
Dwayne the rock Johnson so we would say
his name okay watch rampage in theaters
now Thank You DJ would you rather go to
heaven or become a ghost on earth after
you die well that's great
because you want both is it the reason
that's a good question because you'd
like to be ghost it goes for a little
while until you figure it out and go you
like Swayze yes you want to be sucked
into heaven but you got to go heaven
sorry got to focus your power I don't
want to go to Atlantic City like shake a
window when I could be getting in
ambrosia and a mom just with breasts
asses everywhere that's what I'm
assuming heaven is what is the protocol
and dating your pastor's daughter it's a
hard yes but a pastor's daughter I mean
like yeah then you get in I'm picturing
like basically the movie where it's all
friendly and nice they're spooning a
corn but he gives you a look every once
in a while like in fact and every once
in a while he gives a sermon and you
know he's talking about you know I'd be
in the audience going like how far are
you willing to drive for sex when I was
in college I dated a girl that lived in
Providence Rhode Island and that that's
at least five or six hours from where I
lived and I would drive there for bad
Christian sex
oh yeah well we'd start with it dry than
a moist hump and then maybe the senator
would slip in there and slip into the
Oval Office get a few bills passed and
then he'd leave right before he threw up
[Laughter]